PlayStation Plus is adding a GTA game
among others and Saints Row is looking
to start its Redemption Arc
a week and a half into this month and
Sony has finally announced October's
Playstation Plus game catalog lineup
this month PlayStation Plus extra and
premium members can expect a number of
noteworthy games from lengthy RPGs like
Assassin's Creed Odyssey to tighter
experiences like the Beloved inside and
if spooky Vibes are what you're after
this month then the addition of the
medium may speak to you one of the most
notable additions to the catalog is GTA
Vice City Definitive Edition a game that
launched alongside remasters of its
violent siblings GTA 3 and San Andreas
but also with a ton of bugs and glitches
that hampered fans enjoyment since then
there have been updates and fixes to
improve the game but PlayStation Plus is
a really good way to peek at the state
of the game without committing to the
full purchase I really wish that the
whole trilogy made its way onto the
service this month because when you
think about it Vice City Definitive
Edition was already a part of
PlayStation now for a while so it would
have been nice to see one of the other
ones or the full Trilogy just to kind of
mix things up a little bit and I know I
sound a little bit ungrateful and if I
want to play the other ones I can
purchase the full trilogy but I'm just
saying you know to separate it a little
more from what PlayStation Now was it
would have been would have been nice all
the games will be available to download
from the PlayStation Store starting
October 18th there are plenty of other
games that will be available that we
didn't talk about here so make sure to
check the description for the whole list
and stay tuned for another episode of
our PlayStation Plus themed show for
more about October's offerings but now
that we're done talking about a broken
game from last year let's talk about one
from this year a few months after launch
Saints Row developer volition has begun
prioritizing fixes over new content for
the immediate future Saints Row had a
rough launch back in August one which
was marred by a number of bugs that had
crept into the final game which likely
contributed to the mixed reception that
it received from critics and fans in a
statement volition inside in park quote
right now we feel the focus must be on
telling you how we're going to improve
the Saints Row experience for all
players in 2022 and Beyond there's a lot
more we want to do and right now our
development priority is delivering
improvements over new features volition
expects its next major update to land in
November and it will include more than
200 bug fixes and quality of life
upgrades the developer added that
they'll be a particular focus on
challenges overall stability and co-op
in this update while it works on
implementing bigger and better
Improvement based on fan feedback and
other update news a new update for
PlayStation 5 consoles has gone live and
as usual don't expect it to do much for
your gaming Hardware beyond the usual
performance and stability upgrade the
update is one that modders and home
Brewers will naturally want to avoid as
the PlayStation 5 Jailbreak that went
public this month only works with very
old firmware Sony usually views
modifications of this type as a Gateway
towards piracy and regular firmware
updates have attempt to keep the problem
under control the last substantial
update for the PlayStation 5 was the
September patch that added 1440p support
and folders sorta as well as several
other handy features for the console
this is the second system patch this
month as an October 5th update also
added a few improvements under the hood
now hit the comment section and let me
know your record in fantasy football if
you're in a league if not let me know
your favorite food I'll see you tomorrow
foreign